before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
well the end of the last episode The
Lone Cyberman got away
it's a shame he did not run to a better
story
[Music]
yep folks we are getting to the two-part
finale of Series 12. so that doesn't
mean we are getting
very close to time with children but
first but first uh we need to talk about
Ascension of the cyber men so why don't
we start with my memory of this my
memory of this was that it was a decent
setup that wasn't a great story in and
of itself but it teed things up to
possibly have a good finish and then
Timeless children botched it that's my
memory and it's not wholly inaccurate
but it's very incomplete pretty much
everything that I remembered about this
was all just set up stuff and a couple
of random things like the flying
Cyberman heads
um and that the master jumps out of the
portal at the end and then everything in
the middle was just kind of like not
that I didn't remember at all what
happened well I did in one instance but
I'll get back to that
um it's just that it's it's just working
along until we can get to the next step
so we have to reiterate a shot we have
to sort of show the state of humanity at
this particular point in time and I
don't
I don't remember now if the date
actually gets set as to when this is
supposed to take place
um and it but it's supposedly the tail
end of a massive cyber war that has
wiped out almost all of humanity as well
as almost all the Cybermen and like
that's fine as a premise um I did find
myself wishing that somebody would say
why the Cybermen are trying to destroy
the humans instead of convert them
because like that's their thing and
you'd think especially if they are down
to very few that they would want to
convert them yet they're trying to kill
them and that seems to be the goal and
like beyond that even
I can't remember if it happens in this
episode but at the very least in the
next one when they even get a hold and
like capture them they're still not
planning to convert them they're like
maybe saying kill them away right away
or using them as pawns for something or
something but like why is conversion not
any part of this plan like I could get
it if their main goal would need to wipe
out Humanity because they're a threat to
us but I would think that if they
captured somebody if they got that
opportunity
you convert them
you need the number anyway I'm already
uh getting stuck on something that is
ultimately not that big a detail but it
kind of shows a thing of a lack of
attention to detail this thing has a
decent energy and a pretty propellant
pace and that does a fair bit I think
especially
um with the fog of time to cover up the
fact that there's a lot that I'm not
gonna say it doesn't make sense but
there's a lot of hey wait a minute
moments that aren't unanswerable
it's just the show never does a little
wait a minute to touch on any of them
I've mentioned this in other reviews
before where Moffett when he did it and
he didn't always but when he did he was
actually quite good at this
um was just throwing in a quick line of
dialogue from somebody that just
fills in a plot hole like you're not
sinking time into it but it's just like
one line that basically acknowledges yes
we recognize this and so This Is Us
acknowledging that like we're not going
to spend more time on that and like
that's important sometimes if only so
that as an audience we know it's not a
mistake when you have lines like that to
cover questions like why aren't they
bothering to confer to anybody that
tells us that it's not a mistake you
didn't screw up that's just not the
story you're telling because you're
acknowledging yes we know that it could
be this but we're not doing that we're
doing this and it just takes like little
lines of dialogue somebody just had to
say something like other conversion
um
planets were destroyed or you know it's
something something you know first thing
destroyed was their conversion
technology whatever it just takes one
little line just to cover the base and
it's not done here and that's the one
I'm focusing on but it
shows up in a lot
of things but okay so I mentioned that
there was something that I completely
forgotten about
and it's weird because it covers a fair
bit of this thing
uh that's Brendan
Brendan from Ireland
the found child
becomes a guard and then dies
um doesn't actually regenerate which
feels like a cheat
given what reveal we're building to with
that he ages and then he retires but
then his memory is wiped and there is no
context for this at all
none and sometimes
sometimes
some shows some movies some storytellers
can get away
with integrating something where it's
like what does this have to do with
anything
but some of the tricks that you can use
to get away with that
none of them are employed here so like
for example if it is thematically
consistent with what you're showing so
like if you're doing these you know
scenes of War of struggle of running
away of survival and you cut to someone
who we don't know who they are or how
they're connected or anything what they
are also facing a similar thing while
that still leaves questions of how does
this connect and at least maintains the
flow and the feel and the tone of your
main story so that integrates a little
better then there's just things like
editing flow like picking the points to
transition where it makes sense to do so
as opposed to just randomly sticking it
in between other scenes which is what it
really feels like here
it really feels like it was just the
Brendan scenes were written and then
divided up and like okay let's just slot
these in where we can with very little
sense of flow to it it just does this
and it it just doesn't
be especially when you watched it the
first time you didn't know what the hell
any of it meant even knowing what it
meant it's still badly constructed and
kind of meaningless like I think it's
very telling that there's this much of
this stuff in here but I'd completely
forgotten because even this like what
should have happened is
there should have been a lingering
question and then when I got the answer
I would go
oh but honestly
this barely properly connects to the
answer we're going to eventually get and
I'm trying really hard not to go off on
the Timeless child already because I've
got to do a whole up another a whole
other uh episode on that but like just
briefly
we have a throwaway line later that this
is presented this way
because they're the Timeless tried to
hide it within the Matrix so it wouldn't
be noticeable
why is it set in Ireland then
The Matrix is on Gallifrey
wouldn't an entire section of
information showing The Life and Times
of some Rando on a completely different
freaking planet that theoretically is no
direct connection to califrey at all
wouldn't that stand out more
so like even the supposed cover story
for what this stuff is that doesn't make
any sense heads
not for the internal logic
it makes sense in the
um trick the audience you know basically
present them something that's just lies
but even that like that's cheating
that's that's the laziest way to try and
pull a Twist or to try and pull the rug
out oh it's not what you thought yeah
because you didn't play fair
you presented something as if it was
real and it was all a lie like there are
ways to make that work largely having to
do with characters turning out to be
lying but when the story is lying to the
audience then you're not playing Fair
and it's not
good but again like these are these are
things that in and of themselves in this
episode are just kind of weird and not
great but they don't become problems
until paired with the next episode but
there are some random little things that
are actually kind of good and I kind of
like I like this super ominous voiceover
from a shot as part of the cold open
of course right after the credits we
then immediately cut to freaking baby
Brendan and Ireland so like whatever
Intrigue that build up is all shot
immediately but that just illustrates my
point before about the flow of this
thing there's a moment I really like
um especially especially in the wake of
um where I kind of lost my patience and
lost a little bit talking about uh
hunting a villa Dia Daddy and some of my
issues with that I like that when the
doctor finds this little patch of
surviving humanity and she gets actively
annoyed with them that they don't know
how to build things repair things or use
weapons
one of them just points out we're just
ordinary people we're not soldiers
I was a teacher
rapio was a nurse we got a child minder
a driver a builder and I like that
somebody called her out on that
they're Ordinary People they can't do
everything you would like them to do in
the situation they still matter don't
treat them like garbage you know I I say
that as if the uh as if the doctor was
openly cruel she wasn't she was pretty
unfeeling but again it helps when the
show calls her out on that that having
been said the overall framing isn't
particularly consistent on the deaths of
these Ordinary People because we have uh
while we have the flying cyber heads
showing up which I'm a little bit mixed
on it's a little bit of a goofy visual
but here's the thing
at the state that the Cybermen are in at
this point my head cannon that would
make me more accepting of this is with
their more limited capabilities with
them having lost a whole bunch of
resources with them you know not in
great shape after this war this is the
easy way to build drones is to repurpose
uh the heads of other Cybermen but that
in a more ideal situation where they
have time and resources that's not what
they'd be sending out they'd be putting
together something more
um
you know unique to the task but this is
what they've got that's what they're
going to do of course as I said that is
Handy Canon there's nothing in the text
that supports that and on the other side
of that while I kind of use that to be a
little bit okay with these things
um I also would not have minded you know
a new visual something kind of tool for
the Cybermen I mean we've got the Cyber
mats we know they make stuff like that
why not something new
we get some of the backstory on a shot
specifically the fact that he
volunteered for conversion and that with
its not being complete he is deeply
self-loathing one of the other moments I
really like is the doctor confronting a
shot and you know her pointing out that
he has all this internal conflict that
he clearly hates all the human emotions
that he very visibly has and he just
points out yeah you're right now that's
why I call an inner conflict
oh am I doing this way did you take it
that well now he gives credit to that uh
to being able to work with that
um sort of
um contradiction to the siberium but
regardless I just love that I just love
the the idea of uh of a of a hero doing
the oh you think you're this well really
you're this and like it can be very
cathartic when that's done to throw a
villain off their game or cause a
villain breakdown or just make them
angry and his response is just like yeah
I know and I was like oh
dang okay and like again a shot I shot's
a really cool villain
it's gonna be a real Wasted by uh in the
next episode but he's a real cool
villain that having been said he brings
up the idea that he is trying to
accomplish the quote unquote
and the instant he said that I cared
less like you you already have these
this little grouping of Cybermen
tracking down the last of humanity that
is there's very little left
that's enough Stakes we don't need to
inject freaking diverse reality bomb
nonsense into this and it doesn't really
help that it doesn't track onto the
Cybermen in general like
I I will say as a general rule
threatening to destroy the entire
universe is distancing because I know
you're not ever gonna do that well flux
maybe did we'll get to that eventually
when I get to that re-watch but as a
rule of thumb like the story is not
gonna do that and so the stakes actually
become way less the instance you
introduced that idea now you can still
have Universe ending plots if it adds
something to the villains or tells you
something about those villains and I
would argue that with the case of
someone like davros it does
so that's why I think it kind of worked
back in
um Journey's End and the stolen Earth
but here they just like it's like a
needless let's up the stakes okay it
didn't work and a couple of other random
bits we've got the old guy uh kosharmas
who
he's very much more of a plot device
than a character he exists to open the
the what they call the boundary which is
the portal to Gallifrey but you know
he's he just kind of shows up out of
nowhere with this whole thing and like
they try and play it as a Twist oh it's
a person it's not a place I'm like I
wasn't even you didn't even get me
invested in the idea of it being a place
so again this is a Twist that means
nothing this episode doesn't even really
explain what the hell a shot is doing to
the Cybermen that is like making them
scream and they like make a big deal out
of this moment a cyber man that makes
other cybermens scream like okay what
the hell was he doing they kind of sort
of explained what he might have been
doing but again it's like it's run past
it's a cool moment that in theory should
pay off in some way but it doesn't
really not not as a not as an isolated
moment of like a cool thing but it's
just it's just there now I really did
find myself wondering when the master
jumped through the portal because I was
expecting this time of like has he just
been waiting there for this to open like
has he just been stuck on Gallifrey and
was taking the first opening that showed
up and lucky coincidence because it sure
seemed like he was expecting to see the
doctor how
how like
thankfully they never say I knew you
were coming doctor because like no
there's no possible way but even without
doing that the question is
how are you here like I get why he's on
Gallifrey but like how are you linking
up with the doctor right now how do you
know she's how did you know she would be
here how how any of this it's too
convoluted the the one last thing I'll
say in regards to the Brendan stuff is
at the very end what it gets ominous
it's it's actually quite effective it's
quite Sinister and unsettling in a way
that made me wish the rest of it had
been integrated so that it could the
episode as a whole could build to that
instead it's just it's just one more
thing that happens that works as a kind
of cool moment in and of itself but you
know put into context adds nothing to it
and might even be detrimental to it oh I
forgot to mention before let's talk
about the heads uh they killed a couple
of people one of whom got like
highlighted and a name and everything
and the other of whom didn't and even
when they both die because they do both
die like somebody runs up to the one
whose name we learned and literally
nobody even looks at the other one so
again we're having this issue with Jim
nozera of just a failure to acknowledge
Ordinary People even after somebody kind
of called out the doctor for not being
there for ordinary people and then the
episode just plows right on and does the
same crap
uh
so this this is worse than my memory of
it I do think my memory of it was very
much buoyed by the thought of okay well
this will kind of live or die on where
it's going in and of itself it is either
going to be set up for something great
or it's going to be lesser when I watch
it again because where it goes isn't
that much and it's it's that second one
but where it went is what we have to
deal with next week
oh I've got so many notes on the
Timeless children
please uh Ascension of the Cybermen have
you rewatched it lately if you have
what'd you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it patreons
what pays the bills allows me to do this
as my living you get early access to
videos amongst other perks depending on
what tier of support you do but even if
you can't do that like share and
subscribe the YouTube things you know
what they are and they help me out
but don't worry too much about it
because ultimately what I want you to do
is remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
well it's patreon supporter Shout Out
Time folks so thank you to Robin Moore
Zubin look fulla to rock the thing that
goes doing in the anime Oliver B Angus
bjornison Linda Walters IMU delki
theotha Boyd toy lowly Becky spark for
knobby lacks the poodle Zach Tracy
scrabot General contact unit Problem
Child angry Casper Tim price Adam RDL
Taylor Shayla gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks so much for your help you can get
your name right out too check out the
rewards in the patreon
so what they should do should they check
the patreon
[Music]